we live in a time where everyone wants
to learn about the intricacies of
business operations that is why there is
a massive hype around the masters of
business administration program which
leads to many candidates enrolling in it
without really thinking about the
equation of specialization
they tend to naively choose any
specialization that b schools offers
based on their merits and regardless of
their interests and preferences that's
probably why people end up applying for
a change of specialization which in many
cases gets rejected by the management of
b-schools so instead of just jumping on
the bandwagon having a clear
understanding of your mba specialization
and why it is best suited for you can
prove more valuable for you in your post
graduation and divorce that's precisely
what we are going to learn in this video
today we will cover the practical
approach to choose the right mba
specialization but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
two factors make a significant impact in
your post mba journey the university
from which you have completed your mba
and the specialization that you've
mastered these two factors are going to
stay with you throughout your career
additionally your specialization is an
important component that is going to
define the types of job roles that
you're best suited for
this fact makes choosing the right
specialization increasingly important
and we cannot tell you which
specialization is best suited for you
all we can do is assist you in compiling
a list of factors to look into while
performing self-reflection to make this
decision the first factor on our list is
understanding your strengths it's quite
essential to learn what area of business
you are good at and how you can further
excel in that area
for that you will have to contemplate
your core strengths by performing
thorough self analysis once you have
identified your strengths club them up
together along with your interests and
long-term career goals to get a more
comprehensive picture
doing this will bring you one step
closer to your best suited
specialization
for example if taking the initiative and
leadership are your interests then an
mba in entrepreneurship is the
specialization that you can go ahead
with whereas if you are more inclined
towards numbers or quantitative
information an mba in data analytics or
business analytics will prove to be the
best specialization for you
the next factor is assessing the career
path that interests you the most b
schools know that there are several
facets of business that require adequate
control and hence offer a broad array of
specialization options
marketing finance information technology
and international business and
operations are among those most in
demand career facets if you think you
can sell anything even a small object
like a pen as effective as the
blockbuster movie the wolf of wall
street marketing would be a fantastic
area for you to specialize in whereas if
the sound of money even if it isn't
yours gives you a sense of delight then
a specialization in finance will be a
better option for you
this business management specialization
will help you comprehend how the
financial world operates
next is information technology
technology is now used in nearly every
aspect of an industry thus there is a
rising demand for professionals with a
combination of business and advanced
technical expertise however to get into
the program you'll need an undergraduate
degree in technology
the fourth one is international business
with top mncs expanding their business
beyond borders or at an international
level the need for experts with
knowledge of international legislation
and international trade is growing
significantly that's where the
specialization of international business
comes into play if you're interested in
international trade and legislation this
domain may prove to be an excellent
option for you
finally we have operations if you have
knowledge about manufacturing processes
and product distribution then this
domain is the right place for you to
explore however to get into this program
you will also need a bit of mechanical
expertise related to manufacturing
processes
however if you feel that you cannot
select just one mba domain from this
list
don't worry you can pursue two
disciplines of your choice under the mba
program of dual specialization however
you must determine whether or not the p
schools that you have chosen provides
this type of program the third and most
crucial factor on our list is
compensation band although a higher
salary is one of the most positive
outcomes of this post-graduation degree
assessing the trends for your specific
domain is quite essential you can check
the specialization-wise placements
statistics of the b-school that you want
to get into try to list the minimum and
maximum placement packages for your
choice of domain once you have these
stats analyze which job profiles are
amongst the highest range of the
formulated placement package bands
doing this will give you a fair idea of
which job role you should be on the
lookout for in the future and what
skills you'll need to gain from your mba
journey to attain this role
while compensation is not the only
factor to consider it plays a very
pivotal role nonetheless the last factor
is assessing your career goals your
future career goals and aspirations are
also important things to look into
assessing these factors will help you
plan your mba journey for example if you
have dreamed of launching your own
business and have the required capital
support then an mba in entrepreneurship
is the best post graduation program for
you or if you've been working for a
managerial role for a few years and are
now looking for transition towards
leadership positions and mba in strategy
and leadership can prove a magnificent
asset for you on the other hand if you
have done your undergraduate degree in
technology and felt that technology is
not meant for you then an mba degree can
act as a great career changer for you
these factors will undoubtedly help you
assess which specialization best suits
you so if you're willing to add a
postgraduate degree to your arsenal then
dive directly into a thorough
introspection to recognize which mba
specialization is ideal for you
that's all we have for today i hope
these tips are helpful to all of you out
there and i wish you all the very best
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here